an early morning raid in northern Bosnia
authorities arrested 16 suspected
Islamic militants Bosnia has grappled
with homegrown jihadists for years after
an influx of foreign fighters during the
Bosnian war now hundreds of jihadists
are heading back to the Middle East the
suspects are believed to be involved in
financing organizing and recruiting
Bosnian citizens to head for war in
Syria and Iraq when they're there they
join radical terrorist organizations
earth could be man German airports have
recently stepped up passenger security
checks in an effort to stop the flow of
jihadists to Syria and Iraq
authorities say 28 people have been
prevented from leaving the country this
year but many more have made their way
out though none of the fighters in this
Islamic state propaganda video have been
identified it's estimated that about
2,500 is fighters are from Europe
including more than 400 from Germany
some German lawmakers say the remedies
are at hand if we have evidence that
indicates someone wants to engage in
Jihad we can confiscate his passport and
limit his travel to within Germany so he
can't leave the country off people
described oblique thoughts planted of it
as lovely falafel that may be easier
said than done as 22 countries within
the European Union have abolished border
controls the UN Security Council is set
to hold a meeting this month on the
threat posed by foreign fighters